okay so Jake Paul has been formally
charged with unlawful assembly and
criminal trespassing this past weekend
he was actually in Scottsdale Arizona
where people have footage of him at a
mall at a local mall while they're
looting and it seems like he's just kind
of walking around vlogging it and people
called him out for it he shortly after
went onto Instagram and released a
statement saying that he was out
protesting all day and what he ended up
doing was getting caught in some sort of
situation where he got tear-gassed he
had to go then walk back to wherever he
was staying and somehow are you in the
mall looting you he says he wasn't he
was trying to duck you'd basically
trying to vlog that's fair the protests
yeah you people have me sticking up from
I don't I've never met Jake I know Logan
I know Logan well Logan's my buddy I
don't know his brother this guy does a
lot of stupid [ __ ] nobody Jake Paul it's
so people are looting and you're you're
documenting it like a journalist would
which is what journalists do know he
journalists are sticking up or play the
video chin oh she's not journalists no
is that
that's him God oh he's he's he's doing
this for his YouTube channel and just
commenting on he meets like she's in the
morgues yeah there they go he's kind of
being like oh [ __ ] him and then this is
in the mall right yeah and we're gonna
behavior oh it's criminal behavior where
are the cops
this is Arizona yep
Scottsdale look at this [ __ ] strength
property and stealing a bull well we
don't see him doing him no he doesn't do
hold on did he just say get me a free
clone no this is somebody else who was
at the mall looting and they actually
saw him and notice him they thought he
was his brother Logan at first and so
they're just kind of walking around
following him and that's what this woody
he's not a looter but he's definitely
not you know people don't like that he's
going out of his way to be in situations
like this to monetize off of it later on
YouTube
oh he's monetizing good oh yeah because
he's known for a profiteer on
destruction of property yes what do you
guys think just but this gives him this
gives him content cuz he was I get
tear-gassed we went to the mall with
looters and they're gonna get
tear-gassed so it's like a whole
narrative form so it's like he's
capitalizing on the movement and
everything going on to be absolutely
clear neither I nor anyone in our group
was engaged in looting or vandalism for
context spent the day during our part to
peacefully protest one of the most
horrific in Jessica all right but the us
being tear gassed for for filming the
events and brutality that were unfolding
in Arizona where gas and forced to keep
moving on foot we film everything I mean
I I have to say that he was documenting
it I don't know what he did that was a
crime or that was no crime note say it's
ground no but but I also don't know
criminal charges yeah because no one was
supposed to be inside the mall and wait
he's getting kernel charge because he's
famous they know where he is what about
everybody else I think well it's hard to
identify everyone else who was in the
video he's just a big name yeah yeah I
don't I don't know I'm not so sure if
people are in there and you're [ __ ]
filming it and you're documenting
something
i-isn't that what I I don't know if
that's a crime I don't know if I'm mad
at them no it's not a crime I don't know
I don't know if I'm even mad at that
documenting is not a crime right but but
being in there yeah yes if I go in there
with my camera to capture this moment in
history these [ __ ] these [ __ ]
criminals and [ __ ] who are stealing
and not protesting they're stealing now
you know you got everybody in there
being like they're having a good old
time I'm sorry but they are and they're
breaking stuff and private property and
he's got a camera filming it where do we
put that in the context I don't know I
would say you're part of the problem if
you're younger if you're a young man
yes you're a young man and you go in
there with looters
yeah and film it to upload to your
YouTube page make money off of your
partner making money off it that's a
process he's definitely making money on
photo Brian that's the only reason why
filming ok he's not filming it create
change right he's filming it to make
he's not being placed he's not filming
it gives him content for his page it's
similar to the short talk okay what if
you're standing on the street and you're
documenting it right and somebody's
breaking the windows look CrossFit along
the street and you're filming it and you
put it on your YouTube no you talk about
new Christine hun you went into the mall
with the looters like damn oh my god
there he's still breaking [ __ ] and
filming it so let's say we so we got
Arizona next week yeah and they start
breaking in I go hey Bea I'm gonna get
footage for a final kid yeah YouTube
paid yeah I'm gonna go in there with
them and film it you'd like what the
[ __ ] you and I can like yeah no no I
just wanna like see it dude yeah I think
what are you doing yeah don't be a
[ __ ] it's definitely it's definitely
help shitty
and you're not helping with anything
you're monetizing off looting I'm
personally I'm still I'm not mad at them
oh yeah person I'm still just way bigger
ish
if he would have thrown a break or
something then we should be man exactly
there's way big issue he walked through
and had a video camera I'm not so sure
I'm I'm way mime way more angry at the
people smashing windows and stealing my
anger I don't have any I don't have I
don't have any other mine I have a lot
of anger for him that means I have a lot
of anger for the other people I can see
I can see anger for kids going into
Patagonia and [ __ ] stealing
everything mountain bikes Ferrari I see
here's the prompt
I repeat [ __ ] Jake Paul he's a Miller
looting while people others die
protesting wasn't that's just what
someone's saying but that's the problem
that's the problem is people he's
looting this and the media and then
social media is on there but that's not
the truth yeah yeah it's not the truth
at all yeah well he does have a huge
reach too right so what if he did want
to do something like show the world what
people are doing it's true now that's
fair - wow I haven't seen that I've
never seen a show
does he like show this like this is
[ __ ] up we're trying to do this do we
know it well you don't know what he
intended to do with this particular
footage but he does make shock value
content for kids so it's like his whole
demographic is I think within the ages
of like 12 to like kids even like very
very young yeah yeah my daughter she's
12 it was yeah it's like what was his
intent yeah you want to do with that
footage let's see yeah to play devil's
out here with you cat but it's like you
know yes so how many millions of
followers and maybe it's like hey this
what's going on kids like check this out
man this is what we're dealing with yeah
that's why I'm like you're going through
with a camera and your dock is confusing
for me when I see that that it makes me
mad and it makes me realize that there's
a lot of shitty stuff that Beth has
you're not helping the protester at the
moment you're just being [ __ ] we
filmed everything we saw an effort to
share experience and bring more
attention that anger felt and they were
hood we were travel - all right maybe
all right I'll never really know I have
my best to raise awareness I remember I
have I don't have the energy to
criticize him I have I have problems
with there are a lot of other people eye
problems let's put it that way I don't
have room I don't have room there are
other things Mars is the narrative from
the media scene you
correct or the people yeah I just ran
into something nice right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]